the characters that you do play are you
modeling them after maybe people you've
seen in public where you imagine their
life is a certain way or maybe people
that you grew up with where are you
finding this backstory for some of these
characters are you modeling yourself
after people you've known no no I
suppose I'm not a good enough actor to
do that I suppose that I should observe
people more and try to copy them but
kuren I don't even know if I really know
how to act I've never been trained to do
it I just know how to become other
people and some of the time I can do it
well enough so that people say the you
are in you're really the guy you're
really the redneck you know who's
slashing the Mexicans throw that's a
real guy right that's not an actor I get
this comments of us if I do so I just
keep going to my own dark wall which is
dark enough to draw and then with scare
tactics they are crowdfunding for have
they shot the film or is how we shoot in
September in the fall oh okay and we're
about to shoot here in LA okay thank
goodness yeah the reason that you know I
did this East Coast stage career for 13
years and came here three and a half
years ago and I got really tired of
sleeping on the road because in theater
that's where you make your money on the
road if you're willing to sleep in which
it's all one night and in Louisiana the
next you can make money but I wanted to
be in a place where I could practice my
craft and sleep in the same bed so when
it's an LA shoot always really happy if
it's an out of town see like I gotta go
to New York next month and it's a lead
role and I'm glad didn't have the
feature what I'm like
why can't they shoot it in LA you know
when I was a little girl I would write
letters to Michael Landon and and Scott
Baio and Brooke Shields and ask them how
do I get into the business do they write
back any they did not unfortunately but
I'm not even sure if I sent them to the
right place what would you advise
somebody coming here I mean so many
people think oh yeah go to central
casting and they sign up and you see all
these bright happy people from other
parts of the country thinking that this
is their ticket in what's what's the way
to work in this business
mmm know who you are and know who you
are on camera and try to make them the
same thing because the camera is a great
truth detector and I learned that on
stage you can lie all day long like a
usable comedies and all types of rules
but the camera is right there it's all
eyes and you have to tell them the truth
if you lie on amber you like you too
good and you know work on the camera so
you have to take a real assessment of
yourself look at yourself on camera
don't like what you see there's probably
something to yourself you don't like
because the camera a lion the cameras
the camera is telling the truth the
camera is telling you what you are and
who you are and if you don't like you
can't all I'm going to do a makeover
you'll still be the same damn person on
camera
you've got to accept what the camera
sees if you're going to work on camera
that's what I think
camera acting is a whole different
animal than the stage I know that sounds
kind of nebulous and people want to hear
all I need a good agent they'll do it
for you but if you've got that if you
can say what is it that the camera likes
to see me doing where is that in me and
how can I make a clear channel for that
when I get on set and I'm in front of a
camera it's my friend now because I know
who I am I know what it wants me to do
the camera is like a lover Michael Caine
said that and I find it to be true the
camera knows how it wants you to touch
it if you don't touch it that way it'll
go look at somebody else
it's a fickle lover so you gotta keep it
happy so what if you see yourself on
camera and you don't like what you see
where do you do that in a work you have
to define what it is and now crassly
this is called your brand this is what
you are I tend to be dark on camera I'm
somewhat menacing always a little bit a
little disturbed a little off something
a little strange it's the way the camera
picks me up so I gotta find that stuff
in me and lie a little weird and my
little off the a my a little messed up a
my a little strange yes
acknowledge those parts and embrace
those parts you just can't lie if you
lie and you try to be a camera actor
unless you have really big breasts in
you're 20 years old he will not be a
success and then as soon as you're 25
and you start to get the first wrinkle
it's gone so you know I'm a middle-aged
guy I came to LA I'm nobody from nowhere
from a stage career that was big on the
East Coast but nobody cared about here
so I had to create myself and to create
what I am on camera and make it Who I am
as a person too so this has been really
good for me it's been a good process I
Know Who I am and I think that's what
acting is about right how did you come
to know your type I mean what was it was
it a casting director that pointed it
out when I came to LA
musical comedy and all sorts of light
rolls on the East Coast my agent at the
time Sydney out for these soccer dad
rolls and you know the happy soccer dad
through commercials and you know it's
the acne scars and I have there are all
sorts of scientific studies of what
types of faces make you trust it and
which type don't and I have all the
hallmarks of the face that you don't
trust the deep-set eyes and the uneven
texture and the lengthened face and the
nose I've got all of it
everything about this face says don't
trust me so anyways doing these soccer
dad auditions and this really nice
camera got an audition took me to the
side and he said dude you're the sucker
dad who's gonna kill the team and eat
them he said that's what the camera sees
that is the truth go dark and the darker
you go the more you will work change
everything that's online about you to
reflect that brand because that's the
truth that you are on camera and he was
right as soon as I started doing that I
started working more and working
regularly were you okay with this
evaluation no not at first
the hurt not at first because I had
deluded myself actors are great self
deluder and I had to Lou to myself into
thinking that I was so versatile that I
could do anything and under the right
lights on stage and under the right
makeup you do get fooled by the applause
because you can't do anything there cuz
it's a big tab little bit the camera
again this is it this is the camera it's
from right here there's nothing to hide
behind if you try to hide it's kind of
show in your eyes so accept the truth or
don't worry
I chose to accept the truth the truth of
what I am on camera I know this all
sounds very pretentious
and people might think it's just about
you know stand in front of the camera
and find in my light and looking pretty
and it may be for another actor but it's
not for me
this is the only way that I can work
what was the turning point for you when
your career began to click was it when
that casting director told you this is
your type and you went with that buzz
yeah and how how did that happen I mean
so then you knew okay this is how to
market myself what what was it about
that that took you in a new direction I
came into contact with the person who's
not my manager surely after that I'm
adjacent and we talked about branding
and I have a marketing background I love
marketing for theater and marketed a lot
of the shows that I was in and so it
clicked it's the same thing
I'm laundry detergent I'm tide what kind
of tight in line I get a whole shelf of
Tide what am i I'm creepy tide you've
washed your clothes in me they're gonna
come out creepy no matter what somebody
else may be sunny tide or a whimsical
tide and that's just a silly metaphor of
course but that's the way I thought
about it all right and how do i market
that I'm all casting directors to know
exactly what they get if they cast me
now I have active friends who say ah
dude that's very reductionist you know
you know you should be more broad-based
I don't think so I think people are so
extremely busy that they only have time
to know one thing about you one thing
and so I gave them that one thing and
made it consistent all across the web
without the web I wouldn't be working
most of what an actor can do for
themselves is free it just takes time
and imagination
you